[Musique]
il
6h du matin la mer est calme à bord du
nil nag nous arrivons sur le site
d'aquaculture de sarawak en gaspésie
dans la baie des chaleurs
on est vraiment très de la côte on a à
peu près 20 mètres domicile 20 mètres de
profondeur
[Musique]
ici l'entreprise ça la wec cultive des
algues destinés à la transformation
alimentaire saoud
ça veut dire c'est ça les ans la langue
micmac
[Musique]
adam jérôme et coordonnateur de soutien
pour la gamme une association qui
regroupe trois communautés autochtones
de la gaspésie et du bas-saint-laurent
c'est elle qui pilote le projet sound le
première transformation arrive à shediac
c'est la honte de toi les ags on est
quoi qu' on les congèle le 2e 3e
transformation arrive ici agace kabylia
olap strad c'est là où je produis les
recettes pour notre cas de produits
cette algue c'est la laminaire sucré ou
combo royal elle se marie aussi bien
avec les viandes qu'avec les fruits de
mer ça bien jouer dans ce qu'on appelle
la cinquième saveur on connaît tous nos
quatre saveurs primaire mais la
cinquième saveur qui est mon ami qui est
la saveur iodée les produits ça la règle
ce sont des épices sèche pour poissons
ou pour viande un mélange à tartas est
une relique de mer le chef maxime marmol
de carleton sur mer les a essayé pour
nous juste dans un
un hot dog avec une
une saucisse de boeuf ou une saucisse de
porc artisanale là c'est magique ça va
remplacer vos moutarde ça va remplacer
toutes les petites sauces
d'accompagnement qu'on a l'habitude
d'utiliser dans ce dans ce genre de plat
ici avec un filet de flétan juste grille
est très très traditionnel qu'en valais
justement cherché ce mariage entre le
poisson qui est très souple très tendre
pillaro niche qui va nous apporter ce
petit bout sucre et en plus ce qui est
très intéressant
on a l'impression de manger du fait tant
pour la première fois c'est vraiment
très bon je sais quoi les retombées pour
vous ça down pour valoriser les produits
marins avec toutes les revenus qui sont
produits par salah web ça revient les
trois communautés pour créer de l'emploi
comme sur le bateau nigma depuis pour
les travailleurs à l'absurde
c'est nous ce qu'on veut c'est la petite
algues fraîches que pas beaucoup d'oeufs
bio c'est sûr tout cas pas grand chose
qui vit dessus donc on s'est tourné vers
l'aquaculture sont les en semences vers
le début octobre et
je voudrais neuf mois après ils sont
déjà le bon temps de la belle
tôt prêche le rideau tombe
frêche bien
elle donne envie d'être mangés
elizabeth et son conjoint sébastien ont
fondé simbiosis ils font aussi de la
transformation d'algues aujourd'hui il
met en pause un pesto et des cornichons
de combes où en étais-je de la laminaire
la halle cantine
si je répète de city et on est donc la
seule compagnie à l'heure était qui
les skis pour faire à produit
pour valoriser cette ressource là en
fait c'est un peu comme des cornichons
jeu c'est manger sortie du pot on
applaudit les utiliser ça peut remplacer
les cas d
des recettes donc une sauce tartare par
exemple des caps et de cannes chambre
mais bon instinct blocks marche très
bien à son restaurant le chef maxime
propose un mariage inusité un tartare de
veau aux cornichons de kombu et
canneberges et on sent seul bouillot des
santés la viande santé la canneberge ça
se marie vraiment très bien ensemble de
traits fins et délicieux la ligue 2
reste quand même relativement discrète
mais a bien appuyé là ça mais elle est
présente
il s'arrête ça ne prendra pas le pas sur
le sur la viande c'est délicieux maxime
[Musique]
on ne fait des recettes qui ont dressé
des listes dans du vinaigre
helvea
aromatique rend le goût
intéressant si on faisait justement
la laminaire sucré est aussi délicieuse
en pesto en fait on remplace le basilic
comme apostats
là
pour l'un consistant
et agressions c'est vraiment de live
les saveurs d'un resto
[Musique]
le pesto de cambous notamment le le
sigle ausy cela va vraiment réhaussé
school hop le goût du flétan qui vous a
mené comme si vous mangez au bord du
quai dans la mer ou directement sur le
bateau du pêcheur c'est vraiment bon
[Musique]